Khloe Kardashian reveals why she ditched  her blonde locks what  [Music]  the reality star debuted her updated  look on Instagram last week isn't that  crazy  posting this stunning selfie with a  caption Monday haze go for it  then this Monday the 33 year old and her  hair color guru Tracy Cunningham took to  her app to explain why she traded her  golden do for a darker look that they  dubbed  Braund it's just a ball quote I just  felt like I needed a change I love my  blonde hair but I also felt it needed a  break from bleach most people go dark in  the fall but I wanted to gradually ease  into the dark side and she admitted that  the new shade is taking some time to get  used to my bad Susanna quote it's still  kind of a shock to me so what does  koco's NBA star boyfriend think of her  new strands he loves it he loves  anything  I love lol so that makes me like it even  more lol  [Music]